okay
hello everyone welcome to another design
review for language version 13.
and we are looking today at sound and
vision except at the beginning it looks
like we're all video here
okay so let's
start it off
so in notebook player for video
so what can i see there
how how do i look at this
charlie can you tell me how i look at
this please
create create a video like from example
data
slash
fish mp4 or any other ones
well let's do it from this
and depending on when your build is from
you may or may not be able to actually
see the notebook player
is that
is that really a prototype build that
you're running
two days okay so
the new player is not the default yet in
that deal but if you right click on the
video in on that thumbnail you got
you should be getting those two
front-end appearances switch to
front-end switch to front and minimal
and those names are gonna change
okay i did expect that that that's the
problem we spotted earlier but it's not
fixed in this build you have
okay so so should we look at the idea is
that the idea is that we can have now in
13 or we are
wrapping up this development to have an
in notebook player which is going to be
turned on by default
this is
okay we need to be super careful with
this because it's going to be full of
dynamics it's going to be full of all
kinds of weird things it's like if
you're playing a video
and you've scrolled off screen
does it play even what does the you know
when the when the video falls in the
forest and nobody's there you know what
do you conclude
do you know what i'm saying
i'm sure web browsers when you're
playing a video and you scroll the video
off screen stop playing
are we doing that too either that or pop
them off and show them on the side
okay but i mean what are we doing with
respect to that
so at the moment i think it will
continue playing for sure the audio i am
not sure if the front end is able to
tell
the
pack that is doing the work okay is the
minimal connection
minimal should be the one that goes to
kernel and h
yep that minimal should work
no not the minimal front end but what
you get is gonna be equivalent to the
minimal that you have in there it's
gonna look like that but it's gonna be
more efficient
this
yeah
[Music]
okay
and we have some various controls right
so the minimal doesn't have any controls
if you right click again and switch to
the basic appearance that has some
control
the only one you get here is the play
pause so yep
i see which one will be the default
basic
i i personally prefer basic over minimal
yeah you support that
we'll do this i think so i think it's
better thing
i need to be clear it's a video
now
i'm a little worried about performance
and qa needs to test this carefully
you know if you've got seven videos
running in a notebook
and you know does it like still scroll
or is it goes does it go crazy
it depends very much from the size of
the
raster size of the videos
um okay well we need we need a scheme
that never has it go crazy
i'm saying
so if necessary we haven't tested those
cases but yeah that's a good point you
have to do what happens in the cloud
the cloud has a completely independent
player that just relies on the uh
box from html
that does the whole
if i pick this up
and i say
um
oops what happened there
why is this not typing properly
this has some kind of front end problem
okay that's nice
yeah the problem
work fine
but the typing didn't work though
[Music]
now why doesn't resize work
so if you listen to another name
that
if you resize the notebook the rate size
should work but again yeah charlie was
proposing to have a
resize no we should have resize on this
that will be a nice feature to have
given that we we've come so far in sort
of front end defying this let's let's go
all the way and have a resize on it
and yeah which ends all four ends of
that frame you would expect should be
resized area
i would think so
with this being a floating thing
underneath
yeah just like it does here
um
okay let's keep going i want to see i
mean i'd like to see this once it's
really fully
up and running let's take a look at it
another time and let's make sure that we
have um some ux and design folk
in here
okay
okay
um
okay video with alpha channel
um
okay that's nice i mean is there
something
unobvious about the way that works
what happens in these things yeah that
that seems straightforward and good
it's been requested in previous live
streams actually by the live stream
audience um the things the things that i
think should be um definitely
straightforward is that any any video
from out in the wild that has alpha
channel we should be able to support now
whether we we create video with alpha
channel we are staying on the
conservative side
um
it's not really a common thing and a lot
of the codecs fail when we have alpha
channel there there are only a few of
them that hey listen why doesn't this
work so i'm i'm picking this thing up
right i picked this thing up by the way
i don't even know how to select it
i i try to click here and it doesn't it
doesn't copy that's no good
i can't select this thing
yeah because it's the
the whole thing is a single gui that is
not yeah i understand it is
it should be clickable so that you can
select it right
and if i do this okay so so first point
is when i copy paste it why is it
turning into the black frame why isn't
it the position is resetting because
they say separate instance that's wrong
actually
but then but you want the if you play
one the other one should not play right
they choose
should be cloned along okay yeah i think
so and this should work
image of that
at a particular position
but okay no you don't want the controls
you want image of that to give you the
frame at the given position that's what
i want and if that's playing
if you start playing that what happens
it does its best
so if you right click on what happens
by the way
that's wrong as well rasterize of that
with with the basic appearance should
give us an image of the basic appeal
yeah
but if you want to copy the frame that
is displaying if you right click on the
on the gui there should be a menu item
that will do that
copy so
yeah
okay nice that's very nice but image of
that should just do it
if it's playing so so the
thing that i would argue you because you
could have
that is just image of video of something
right so that could be an input film it
doesn't necessarily display something
um
uh say that again
uh
gui
its input form is just video of whatever
it does not the kernel does not
necessarily know what is the frame that
is being displayed
or you could assign a variable to it
right but why don't you why doesn't it
wait a minute
so
look i think when it when at least when
it's paused i mean i i i would i would
admit that when it's playing
you know you can just have the black
screen you know you can just have the
first when it's playing if you say image
of a playing thing
it's fine to just go to the initial one
what does image of a manipulate do
fail
but i was just looking at manipulate the
whole manipulate is not selectable
what is displayed inside of it is
selectable and you can copy that over
okay
is is that gonna be actually no the
thing that is selectable you cannot
still copy and paste it elsewhere yes
you can
yes you can
okay listen we got the wrong group to
discuss this we want to discuss this we
need to have a meeting that includes the
front-end people
yeah
uh well and we need to do that control
command-c didn't work by the right there
is a right click menu saying copy
graphics
and that works
well actually no that's not what i was
thinking
look again we we need the front end team
here okay so i've got this i click that
i press copy i paste it it's all good
okay didn't work for me in documentation
let me check well i don't know what's
happening in documentation that might be
a different bug
that was a yeah didn't work in
documentation you're right works
works outside okay so you need to do
that yeah acceptable well so
i i would say click on the behavior to
get the image
and then
i wouldn't be horrified
well we gotta we gotta have both a
resize
yeah it's gotta be able to resize as
it's playing so you click it it's still
playing you press copy it copies the
frame at the time when the frame is is
um
um
you know at the time you press copy
making sense
my only concern is that click
on the minimal gui is pausing and
replaying
and i'm wondering how that's going to
interact with the questions
wrong group okay please get the ux
people and get them to actually look at
this don't try and wing it
okay okay maybe you can get christina to
try and give you some comments on this
okay
yes christine
bateman
okay
as job is analyzing ux behavior
right
okay
but please don't wing it we got a whole
ux group right let's not ignore them
um
make sense
yep
okay
improved
url streaming
ethan is asking if that's the basic look
what does advance look like i think we
can't show right now because
uh
yeah the creature is about to get run
over no no it's it's some
uh it's just not working right now
okay improved url streaming is that that
more of an implementation issue or is
there some functionality change
implementation
okay summary video is that something we
discussed before
uh no
or maybe we did but but if in if so it
was just sort of an offhand remark this
is the idea of doing snapshots or
summary of a video
let's say you want to build a trailer of
your talk
yeah maybe you want to capture the most
dramatic moments and it's very easy
v very easy user interface to it
summary video percent three
no you need to do you need to say what
time points do you think are dramatic
what what do you want but but but no i
mean it's not the same thing as video
frame list right i mean video frames no
no
go look at read read rtfm
it's got the wrong name then
no i think video constructors should be
ending with video no i agree with that
but i think summary video
i think i mean this is
okay by the way i think a better name
for it my candidate name for this was
snapshot video
um looks like a better name to me
does does docutools work in the new
builds or is it going to crash
everything if i try and run it
i've worked with it recently
shall i risk it
i would say yes
ah
great it didn't do that
um
so i don't understand is this a version
of video frame list
no it's not oh it's a video yes it's a
video like video frame list
what i don't know what you mean by that
no i mean
how do i this video here this thing here
i can turn into a slideshow video right
no
well what do you mean we that's what we
made slideshow video a percent nine
turns that into a slideshow that's what
we discussed i see
yes yes yes
but those are static
i know i know i know i got it
okay so that's that
um okay so what this is doing
turns a summary video
so this is something which is is is like
a trailer you say yeah
okay but why can't i just do so like
video frame list has a syntax for
different kinds of things you can
specify in the video frame list right
well actually it doesn't it's just n
what is our thing that that has oh it
video extract frames right that's the
thing that does this with t with time
steps right
yeah but we don't want frames we want
video segments i i understand i
understand i'm saying
if you wanted to summarize the video
instead of giving a video slideshow by
giving a sequence
of video clips
and video clips right
yeah
so why isn't that i mean
i don't know whether that's a compelling
thing to do it is i've been using it for
years no no but but if you just like
video frame list has equally spaced 10
equally spaced time points
right
i mean i'm asking the question
if if this was equally spaced time
points would it be useful probably not
okay so that's my question so i i'm
going to try
in this case right so this was one
minute i mean what do you mean a zero
argument that sort of could be a default
i mean a one argument thing well that's
just a number here yeah i get an n
right so so okay so let me try here so i
think that the key
keep
you know what we forgot and this is
really important is to have
you know the final duration to make you
know do you want the 30 second summary
one minute there is a there is a
duration of default duration option
that kind of option yeah okay well okay
fine but but so then this
okay so what i want to do is i want to
say table i mean this is kind of a pain
and i'm illustrating how much of a pain
it is
right quantity t
seconds right no you don't need to use
that just use the dmt default this
second yeah we don't know okay all right
okay okay so then then if i say summary
video
of
that first video here
percent three
but you have to find the tease that you
find
i i'm aware of what you're saying i
understand what you're saying
i'm i'm trying to understand if i just
say range t 0 60
10 for example
okay i want to know what this does okay
okay
bye
[Music]
[Music]
that was surprisingly compelling
did it really do 10 different things so
30 seconds is the default okay so six
different things
did it really do two things yes it did
yep yes it did okay well it was very
agreeing i agree with you it was
more well this is a very dramatic video
but a lot of things that people shoot
with their family outings and other
things are not as compelling well let's
let's do the following i mean we you
know and i think the same thing is with
talks most talks are not that compelling
all the time
right but i mean you know we have got a
great example let me show you a big
example here
which we could test this on
um
but i'm not exactly having a one
argument no i understand but you know
friendly case of these right right and
you know this you know who knows what
this i mean
you know i mean to me well these ones
are not quite as as exciting but you
know they're not terrible these are not
terrible
so can you yeah let's get the one minute
summary yeah
no why not
and let's see what happens if i go to
full screen it's not that exciting
um
but you know it gives some sense here
and i think the one minute summary will
be very interesting for these let's try
some
see what happens
um i think it will be particularly
relevant i mean i don't know that this
well this has been very successful this
is oh for god's sake these summaries are
just bonkers
bonkers bonkers bonkers but the word
clouds are great
um
just a minute
so
okay
well i'd like to see this running on
some other things and i would like to
see
i mean
you know to me
it's not obvious to me here's an example
in chat
this is from
four years ago or something like that
it's from
oh
this is yours yeah
okay
right now i mean this is lovely roger
but i'm already
marginally bored
but this should be i think i can't
remember if it's 30 seconds or
well wait a minute are you saying this
is a video i should i should try and
summarize no no this one is a
summarization of
many hours oh my gosh of many hours of
video right okay
five hours
okay but so roger
you know this is a good example of where
if you just give me
you know i'm trying to get a texture of
what's going on okay
and so you just give me sort of five
random spots
that's gonna be no random it's not gonna
be good
is that right really i mean you're going
through a wood
no wood no but this this sort of you
want to find
what when you watch a bunch of these is
that you want the compelling things it's
same thing when you go on a vacation you
don't want
you want the thing where someone makes a
goofy mist you know goofy joke or makes
a
like in his writing if someone's not
buying it i think that the problem is
roger
that
i agree with you if somebody with loving
care you want the drama yeah
um you know if there is no drama in your
lecture then fine do it at random
probably going to be the same
look i have to say
those video frame lists that we've got
from these videos that i've done
hundreds of them now
right
are
um
you know are surprisingly useful they
give a texture of the video they're not
selling the video like a like a trailer
does but they give a texture of it
and that's useful so my question here is
what
machine learning capabilities or
whatever do we have
i thought we had some ways for finding
sort of that's with that's part of what
we talked about for the future
can we find what's interesting and we
don't know of anything right now yeah i
think we can do that i i kind of want to
save that automatic time selection for a
future round as well but but i thought
that we had the capability to find for
example
uh scene changes don't we have that
right now we can okay it's not at top
level but you yeah we have examples with
video map time series to do that
okay so
i mean that seems like a minimal thing
to do here
one disadvantage that i would bring up
is that that needs to analyze all the
most of the frames so
it might take a long time okay guys
i'm going to give you a reality check
okay
the thing you're doing here
which is kind of semi-automated sort of
a particular kind of video editing blah
blah blah exactly i i yeah i understand
i don't believe in it i think that two
things make sense i think the fully
automated version makes sense where
you're just like i've got 100 videos i
just want to see
you know i just want to get some rough
summary of all of them like hundreds of
you know hours of our live streams i
think that makes perfect sense just like
our video frameless thing makes sense
there and so on it's good it's a
worthwhile thing and i think the thing
where there is tender loving care
and
very detailed you know either
automatically or by hand you know like
for example let's say the workflow is
this okay
let's say my workflow is i
wipe across here and i say wait a minute
that is the frame i want boom that's
around just this place that's what i
want
okay i wipe along again like can i
extract the the um
the location the time location is there
a way to do that is there a way to go
from
this
to extract the time step
like from here right so from this it was
it was one of the ideas that we had but
not implemented yet but as you we have
the right click menu that copies the
image it would be
just a position yeah you should say
copy copy time location or something yep
yep okay because that to me
is another realistic workflow i agree
but but but i i would say
that what you would want to do
if we're going to do summarization like
this
i mean i just don't get it i mean it's
like it's like video editing software
which we are not
right allows you to just take the
timeline and select an area and say okay
that's what i want select another area
that's what i want i can see people
doing that
i can also see people just saying i want
to press the idiot button so to speak
the easy button and i want to just make
it you know make you know just like this
is a pretty reasonable summary of this
video is it perfect no
but these things and the video frame
lists that we're using for the live
streams are surprisingly compelling
can i explain why not really but they
give a texture of what's going on
um
and you know what i think we should be
doing is
um you know we should be using whatever
heuristics we can
sandra is mentioning uh
uh sound intensity changes that's
another
um cue
but
but i mean
you know
i i just don't believe in this i i think
that this is a
you know
why aren't you just using video trim you
know you map for this particular
operation which i do not believe in you
can map video trim against a bunch of
duration pairs right
a bunch
yes but that's also going to be tedious
this is going to be easier
how tedious is it wait wait wait wait
wait wait how tedious is it you just
went to huge effort to find the
special places
where
roger jumped his whatever that weird
vehicle what is that vehicle anyway
it's a mountain bike or something it's a
mountain
what is that it's a motorbike yeah it's
called a dirt bike i don't but i'm sorry
roger i knew that um okay
the moment when roger jumps his dirt
bike over a river or something okay
and um
uh
so
my point is
you've you've with with careful care
you've found that at two hours 15
minutes and 12 seconds roger jumps his
dirt bike okay i mean a lot of effort to
find that no but but if no well yes and
no but if you experience it yourself
you might know what you think might be
interesting
right
like if you gave the talk you might know
what is interesting
or maybe you don't i don't know i mean i
just gave a long talk this morning i
don't know what but they you know i
thought there were some interesting
things
that but god knows where they are in the
talk and so on um
you know and um i mean it's a lot of
work to go find that
um
so how about something like
in the second argument we say uniform
sampling as the method instead of t1 t2
comma the number of samples we think we
want to graph and still expect that the
user would provide us that but not do
anything by default one form
okay
the one argument form i don't care about
the one argument form i think is over
over whatever i mean maybe there's okay
we may find that there is a useful one
argument form i do not know
okay
that that's a question
of you know can we make the machine
learning work i just i'm not familiar
with it i i you know as i say
video frame lists are so we
fully expected to get
interesting
one or symbolic forms i mean there can
be different notions of interestingness
you know there can be string values
there in the second argument okay well
fine but but then then the question is
what i think is the case
but i really do think that this is the
most important case that you don't
believe in
i don't believe in it i mean i don't
understand why isn't this i don't
believe
what's that look i don't believe in your
video trim
of of you know it's a bunch of pairs
right it's a bunch of doubles no isn't
it
because you want to give the total if
you want the 30 second summary and i
have four they can be different length
than if you have five things to get in
there
okay
all right
this does not feel well cooked to me why
not
it's just what but these string
objectives that you're proposing what
i'm saying is that uniform sampling is
the string method that you provide in
that second argument potentially with
the number of samples we take from the
video so it's going to be either uniform
as as a single string or a list of
uniform comma five and then we go figure
it out or shelly maybe even forgo the
string because it is unambiguous to
have a
integer of the second argument just say
five and i guess interpreted as
uniformly sampled and we can have both
usages the one that's uniformly sampled
and the one that is implemented
currently where the user has to specify
which times he thinks and how does that
relate to video frame list is that how
video frameless works as well yeah
it would be the equivalent of video
frameworks
yeah thank you then there can be another
string that's called random
for instance yep
sure
or the value of the method option um
yeah
okay what was your suggestion for a
slightly less ambitious name roger
a snapshot video
because you get a bunch of snapshots
basically
except that snapshot suggests a snapshot
suggests a static object yeah i agree
with you a little bit but but you you
think video
oh yeah maybe a snippet yeah actually
that's a better name but what is that
isn't there a name for
for a a short piece of video what is
that called
well snippet is such a thing right right
i mean i was thinking of snapshot as
also denoting video but i really think
it's more commonly filmed well why don't
we call it snippets plural video
snippets video
yeah
not a video made of snippets not a bad
name
all right
um
okay and i think with an n there if
that's how video frame list works
which i mean i you know i have to say
when i use video frame list
pretty much a hundred percent of the
time i'm using it with its just its n
argument which i really like
you know i find it really useful
well that's all it does video frameless
that's all it does that's all it does it
does have a method option which is
uniform or
but it's very dumb right now so
yeah
if we
not the method level but if we
introduced a second argument with string
you know that could be uniform command
which is what it does
a random command well why aren't we just
taking the case why aren't we allowing
video frameless to take a t t sub i
second you know a list of two yeah they
could do it could be generalized in the
same sense sense well it then it really
does exactly the same thing no
this is a video frame list it makes a
list of video frames now carlo is saying
that's going to be the same as
yeah video extract right
oh
okay well let's look at that
but there was a different default video
extract frames has another yes
at time t
and that could be a list of times as
well
right but this is why i think there's a
bit of a
you know so so here's my question
um
well maybe this one isn't needed then
you know maybe it's just video frame
list and we can get rid of this one
which one video of your stretch frames
no no we we specifically put this in
yeah they serve slightly different
purposes one is the automated extraction
this one is the one
where the user has to think about what
he's doing okay listen
i think it would be
i think we originally had something
where it was either a number n
or the list of times and i think that's
yucky
particularly if we allow the times not
to be with units
you see what i'm saying
yes
the difference is that in the previous
one we allowed a single time
in the frame extracting one and that was
ambiguous for them
with the snippets video
the times need to be in the list but i
see your plan i know but it's kind of
yucky
someone came up with a name clips
video extract clips i really think that
we should have things ending in video
that construct video yeah i kind of
think so too i think video extract clips
would be a list of
yes
a list of video clips which would also
be a potentially useful function
yeah
but does this video trim
well does it for one
one or multiple intervals
but doesn't do it around
specified times
right
ah somebody on the on the um
howling on the live stream suggest video
extract clips is a good name
i mean i think clips is a good
thing like frames
i like that idea
but i'm not quite sure how to use it i
mean
i mean instead of yeah the clips was the
word i was looking for when i said
snippets and maybe we should call it
clips video
sounds a little bit more awkward yeah i
was just going to say that a little bit
all right listen let's go on a bit i
think we need to come back just because
we need to come back for the
um
uh ux stuff anyway and as you know i i
have to finish here and not too long so
i just want to get some sense of what
else there is
graphics tour video
that sounds exciting
oh for goodness sake don't make me have
to give the frigging points that's the
thing which is interesting is being able
to do this without giving the points
right
right i mean that that's but even if you
just do
we think that we've done a lot of
simplification for for sort of video
construction you want it even simpler i
do that will make people actually use it
right so this is i mean this is what we
have to do i mean even if all you do
this is not for graphics 3d that's
coming but that's not it
okay what what what is it what is it
graphics is for graphics it's not for
graphics 3d okay
again i don't think in your build this
is going to work but okay
look at the next when you provide it
there is no example roger in the recipe
yeah okay well then we're not ready
yeah then we're not ready okay
however i think this can't be
theoretically reviewed
yeah it just travels over your graphics
from the points to that that from the
points that are specified goes from
point one to point two i get it i get it
it's a nice idea with a certain size of
of uh a sort of um window or something
is that correct yeah yes we yeah we
automatically compute the size if it's
not provided but there is the more uh
elaborate specification that we provide
size and so
it allows you to zoom in on things yeah
i get it i get it it's a nice idea i
mean i think that um
uh
right
um
so it's kind of a way to do you know a
video highlight of something no no i
agree what about graphics what about the
3d case which seems to me to be the most
interesting right but yes it will be but
but it requires we we're just beyond
scope of what we could by the way there
was a summer school project that was
pretty nice this year which had to do
with optimal rotations of 3d objects
finding the interesting you know finding
the places finding the angle that's a
good angle to show a 3d object had
okay
i think that might be relevant to that
that was the static case of this which
by the way we could consider
for a you know
view
viewpoint arrow automatic or something
i think it has i mean
yeah it probably should be string
interesting or something but it's fine
because i i think it has value of comp
you know being able to compare things
you know oh i agree with you i agree
with you so i don't know what we whether
what we have right now is probably
automatic set to automatic but yes i
agree it's um you know
uh yes but i think it's a we we should
look at that it's a worthwhile thing
here no it is
um
ethan is asking for machine learning
with video
it is coming
do we have it do we have things to say
about that yet yes
you can use videos yeah there are oh
look at this that encoder what do you
know
that was there before as well the net
encoder wasn't it was already a useful
net encoder in 1203
um design is changing there slightly
what's exciting is that there are a good
number of networks classifiers converted
and are going to be available in the net
repository we're going to be using one
of those as a feature extractor and it's
going to be a reasonable extractor as
that description says
so that means we'll be able to do
machine learning with videos basically
that's the bottom yeah
we already are but it's a bit dumb
hopefully we'll be better
okay that's cool
um
okay marco is suggesting a live stream
actually a very interesting idea an
option to extract slides from a video of
a presentation
that's an interesting idea
in other words somebody has shown
a random presenter tools you know
powerpoint whatever thing and all you've
seen is that
and can you make a frame list of the
slides
do you see what i'm saying
yeah yep
it's a good idea
it sounds like a cool
functional repository function well but
it's also something which should be the
default action of one of these snippets
video things
no not snippets video it's a it could be
a version of video frame
it sounds like slideshow video
no no no roger
slideshow video i know the inverse i
know but i'm just saying slideshow
videos sounds like it would take a
slideshow
no but it's it's returning a video
because it has the word video at the end
this is a it sounds video takes a
slideshow notebook and produces a video
look what it's doing is it's producing a
list of frames
so what it really is no i i understand
i i yes it's a video frameless with a
second argument type thing
um
that that's really i think the same as
the scene change um it is right i know
it's a very good use case for scene
change yeah
yeah and it's one where very clean use
case for scene change
you know because it's probably kind of
do that carlo
even 413 i think we could do a string
let's if you agree we can move up that
method option to the argument
and add this scene change to it as well
right but i'm what i'm saying is video
frame list
right
could have that
argument instead of saying video
frameless 12 or something you could say
video frameless quotes
scene changes or something exactly okay
exactly right i love it
right and maybe there's a second thing
where
scene changes and then that you know 10
or something which is a maximum i don't
know
um
okay i just want to get some sense of
what's happening here
ah
oh boy there's a lot of stuff here
it usually takes us a few
few of these before we get through it
future you know me too yeah
okay
well let me
um
you know this is going to be another at
least two solid hours
i know
do you want to do it in one hour at the
time or do you want to schedule a
two-hour thing
i think if we can get the right people
in there i'm happy to do a two-hour
thing but i don't care it doesn't matter
they can be done in in in in
one-hour blocks or as a single two-hour
thing but let's please make sure the
right people are on call and that's not
you know we've got we need respects and
design for this
um
and uh
ethan is pointing us to exporting export
rotating gif in the function repository
which is
um that's interesting
right i mean that's exactly the kind of
thing we're looking at is
is what does this involve i don't know
how this works but that's exactly the
kind of thing we're looking for
yeah that's the
um
that would be the graphics 3d tour video
kind of obviously obviously
obviously i mean i would assume that
there's also an image tour that we could
do too yeah that's that's what we
started with the graphics tour was an
image to her and that because that is
implemented actually
yeah the idea is that graphics store
could take image or graphics
i don't know why you know
it's kind of obvious to
why don't you just have a a um
uh
what is the right thing
it's kind of a spatial tour it's kind of
a a um
um a fly through type thing
bob is saying we like to take this live
stream extract the notebooks and run
them
yeah
yeah well that's a that's a good vision
i mean it's not impossible we've got ocr
we've got um
um
you know if things are high enough
resolution there's no reason one can't
find
the notebook window
um
that's an interesting thing whether
whether it's possible to find that's
another thing i could imagine wanting to
extract is from screen captures extract
windows
you know what i'm saying
i don't think we have that yet as an
image processing operation but it seems
like an interesting one to have
right um
well there's a lot of interesting stuff
here i think we need to
continue uh
another time
and um
yeah fine we'll we'll start scheduling
them and sounds good i look forward to
it
um okay good stuff very nice work okay
see y'all soon okay thanks